what is the hierarchical cluster
analysis and how is it calculated that's
what we'll discuss in this video let's
start with the first question what is
the hierarchical cluster analysis a
hierarchical cluster analysis is a
clustering method that creates a
hierarchical tree of objects to be
clustered the tree represents the
relationships between the objects and
shows how objects are clustered at
different levels but let's look at this
with an example we asked people how many
hours a week they spend on social media
platforms and in the gym we now want to
know if there are classes in this data
set and perform a hierarchical class
analysis how do we calculate a
hierarchical class analysis the first
thing we do is plot the people on a
scatter plot with this we can now start
to create the Clusters
the first step is to assign a class to
each individual point
so we have as many classes as we have
people
the goal now is gradually merge more and
more clusters until finally all points
are in one cluster
but how do we do that in each step the
classes that are closest together are
always merged what does closest together
mean for this we need to establish two
things one how to measure the distance
between two points two how points are
connected in a cluster
let's start with the question how do we
calculate the distance between two
points here are the most famous ones the
euclidean distance the Manhattan
distance and the maximum distance
let's take the distance between Max and
Caro the difference on the y-axis
results with one and the difference on
the x-axis is 4. the euclidean distance
is just the square root of the sum of
the square differences it is calculated
as follows
square root of 4 squared plus 1 squared
which is
3.162 for the Manhattan distance the sum
of the absolute differences is used so
we simply calculate four plus one and
thus get a distance of 5. the maximum
distance simply uses the maximum value
of the absolute differences in this case
4. now that we know what ways there are
to calculate the distances between
points we still have to determine how
the points within a cluster are linked
let's say we have a cluster with the
points Joey and Lisa and the class with
mags and Carol now how do we determine
the distance between these two clusters
here are the most popular methods single
linkage complete linkage and average
linkage
single linkage uses the distance between
the closest elements in the cluster so
the distance between Caro and show
complete linkage uses the distance
between the most distant elements of the
cluster so between Max and Joe
average linkage uses the average of all
pairwise distances from each combination
the distance is calculated and from it
the average value
for our example we use the euclidean
distance and the single linkage method
so we need the distance from each
cluster to the other clusters
for this we must first calculate the
distance Matrix in the distance Matrix
we plot the Clusters on each of the
dimensions and then calculate the
distances from each cluster to every
other cluster
the distance between Allen and Lisa is
given by the square root out of 5 minus
2 squared plus 2 minus 3 squared which
is
3.16 the distance between L and Joe is
given by the square root out of 5 minus
2 squared plus 3 minus 3 squared which
is 3. we can now do this for all other
combinations until we have calculated
the entire distance Matrix now we can
merge the first clusters for this we
look at which two clusters have the
smallest distance between them this is
the case between Joe and Lisa so the
closest distance we have is between Joe
and Lisa with this we now connect Joe
and Lisa to form a cluster in our tree
diagram or dendrogram we can draw the
first connection now we need to update
our distance Matrix we decided to use
the single linkage method so the
distance between two clusters is given
by the elements that are closest to each
other to the Clusters Ellen Max and
Carol from the class Lee Sancho
respectively Joe is always the closest
person so we calculate the distance from
L to Joe the distance from Max to Joe
and the distance from Cairo to Cho now
we put back together the classes that
are closest to each other this is Max
and Ellen
in our tree diagram or dendrogram we can
draw the second connection now we update
the distance Matrix again we calculate
the distance between Ellen and Joe Caro
and Joe and between Cairo and Allen we
obtain the smallest distance between the
cluster Caro and the cluster Lisa and
Dro so we connect these two classes and
draw the third Connection in the tree
diagram now there are only two classes
which we merged in the last step and we
get our finished dendrogram and now I'll
show you how you can easily calculate a
hierarchical cluster analysis online
with data tab if you like you can load
the data set and calculate with it in
parallel you can find the link in the
video description to calculate a
hierarchical cluster analysis online
just visit
datadeep.net and copy your own data into
this table or use the link to load this
data set
then the variables social media and Jim
appear here below now we click on
cluster and select hierarchical cluster
if we now click on social media and Jim
a hierarchical cluster analysis will be
calculated additionally we can specify
the label in our case the names of the
people now we can specify which
connection method should be used and how
the distance should be calculated again
we take the single linkage and the
euclidean distance now we get the
results down here we see the tree plot a
scatter plot and the elbow plot in
yellow plot we can now read how many
classes we take we can see a king here
so we take four as the cluster count we
can select the number of classes here
and then we get the four clusters
highlighted by different colors in the
tree plot we see the first cluster the
second the third and the fourth cluster
if you don't know what the elbow method
is please watch our video about it I
hope you enjoyed the video see you next
time